all right we'll see what happens here we
have two major categories of food that
we process one is freeze-dried we also
have a number of products that we
produce that our therms stabilized I am
utterly excited right now this has
always been a dream of mine to see stuff
like this all right so three things
we're gonna use tortillas chicken with
peanut sauce and pineapple just for
texture and flavor let's see how this
looks on so very regular tortillas so I
want to take this flour tortilla is
almost break it up as like a pasta if
you will just to have some texture so
chicken with peanut sauce ooh so it's
very much a shredded up rice noodle it's
it's amazing smelling can I taste this
it's soupy it's very kind of dimensional
for this I would want personally like
some chilies and some herbs I think it's
good though I mean if I was gonna be up
there in space it would be something
that'll be very fulfilling pineapple
I'm very fresh and clean tasting though
some pineapple some pear and just kind
of make like a little salad if you will
a little relish something I know that
they won't have just a touch of mint
chicken looks like it's moist so I'm not
gonna argue with that I would eat this
it's got the flour tortillas the pasta
kind of the sauce that's kind of and
then just the chutney and then if he had
a little chili on top of that I would
definitely crush that it's like a taco
but not
either if you like I just ate a taco I
eat this whole thing because it is a
little bit heavier this is a Rosie from
Joe Kalina so chef Alina Rosa has a
little bit of more acidity and and then
it also has some effervescence to it so
it kind of uplifts and we'll kind of
clear this out on the palate kind of
happy right now the presentation is very
nice I'm sure our crewmembers wish that
they could do something like this on
station I just have to eat out of the
packages unfortunately this is a dream
come true for me to see this to taste it
to actually experience this in life
as a kid growing up I've always wanted
to see how this came across that's
awesome thank you you're welcome